many schools across the country are
closing for the rest of the academic
year due to the pandemic so far 19
states have announced that schools will
not reopen this spring in New York City
the mayor says the nation's largest
district with more than a million
students will not reopen Meg Oliver
joins us from outside her home in New
Jersey where the governor says schools
are closed indefinitely good morning meg
Anthony good morning behind me is our
version of shop class this homeschooling
is not easy and as tens of millions of
students move to online learning for the
remainder of the school year many are
struggling to keep up and some aren't
even logging in as schools report a
drastic decline in attendance
experts warn students are rapidly
falling behind
senior aja Brian thought this spring
would be one of celebration wrapping up
her high school softball career in
graduating your high school graduation
has been canceled how do you feel about
that honestly truly and sad about it
that was a landmark for me I was gonna
be like of course she was gonna be like
a big exhale for me there has been no
exhale for Bryant since her Los Angeles
high school moved to online learning
she's worried about falling behind do
you have a spotty internet connection
yet Brian said her internet often
freezes in the middle of lessons we
witnessed her spotty connection
firsthand did you freeze I think you
froze darn it hang on Brian says she's
still logging on and doing her work but
that's not the case for all students in
the Los Angeles Unified School District
the district says for the first two
weeks of online learning 15,000 high
school students did not log on at all
that has since been cut by about
two-thirds many districts scrambled to
get students devices like laptops and
Wi-Fi after schools closed but there's a
lot of catching up to do nearly 12
million children do not live in homes
with an Internet broadband connection
Dallas teacher aundrea Bazemore works at
a school with a lot of students from
low-income households I had a student
who was doing her reading lessons we
were on such a great momentum but we had
to stop about 10 20 minutes in because
her data had run out and her mom said
hey I gotta stop I need to go somewhere
with Wi-Fi because I didn't my Wi-Fi in
house Bazemore is communicating with
parents anyway she can like over text
she started hosting virtual pizza
parties with a different student each
Friday as encouragement I solicited some
donations from friends and family and
through those donations I'm able to
provide a pizza at their doorstep forget
all the things that are happening in our
world today and just have a relaxing
moment are you concerned that they're
gonna be left behind oh I'm absolutely
concerned we talk about summer slides
right students decline over their
reading and math skills over the summer
we're gonna have a corona slide and it's
going to be very very significant
education expert dr. Karen Aronian
agrees she said data is already pointing
to a very steep decline this is a crisis
right now we know we're looking at with
reading a 30% drop and in math 50% for
this time frame Aronian thinks districts
should begin utilizing retired and
substitute teachers to help reach
students who don't have internet or
devices those potential families would
be linked to a teacher that lives there
behind them who could drop off a packet
of academic work once per week and check
in with them daily despite her own
challenges aja Bryant is hopeful she
plans to attend Community College in the
fall where she will play softball
I hope somehow someway I could continue
to do what I love I think hopefully
playing there as well it gives me a
fresh start a round of applause for Asia
because she keeps bugging on despite the
challenges
the Los Angeles school district said
they will not fail students during this
period now back here in New Jersey some
school districts have suspended Spring
Break requiring students to continue
online learning thankfully that didn't
happen in our district we needed a break
so Anthony this is our attempt to build
a tree house good luck with that Meg as
I've often said here my wife's a teacher
right my wife's a teacher and it's an
incredibly challenging time to keep this
the kids attention and connected
particularly because of the technology
issues you talk about you know hats off
to the teachers who are doing it it's
really hard work Thank You Meg